so pretend you're stuck in traffic
you're super frustrated you're gripping
the wheel tight you can't believe that
you're late for work and it's your first
day and you just landed your dream job
and it's bumper-to-bumper traffic and
you can't do anything about it how does
that make you feel probably pretty
frustrated right
why though okay a new scenario imagine
you're walking down the street you're
having a great time you say hi to the
lovely couple and they say hi right back
at you there's a catholic priest walking
a little chihuahua and you say good
evening father and he says good evening
my son and i felt really good you're
like okay there's a cool cast of
characters here and then you wave at the
third and final guy he's like [ __ ] you
man stay away from me unless he was a
king of dry humor that would probably
hurt a little bit but why would that
bother you now these might sound like
stupid questions why would it bother me
obviously it would bother me like being
stuck in traffic 10 minutes late to work
when i just landed my dream job is my
first day and there's a situation
completely out of my control it's just
so indicative of my life nothing ever
goes my way or obviously i'd be mad if
someone said [ __ ] you that's insulting
i'm just trying to lighten the mood and
this person spits right back in my face
but there's a problem being angry and
rattled over situations completely out
of your control often leaks into
the rest of the day right like you get
frustrated over a situation it doesn't
just last the duration of that situation
you harbor that negativity and it leaks
into your relationships into your career
into your family life you know maybe
you're stuck in traffic on your first
day at work and you finally get into the
office but you're rattled and you're
pissed off and you're flustered and you
have a horrible day at work you make an
awful first impression a far worse
impression than just being late for work
so there's almost no utility to being
rattled about situations outside of your
control so now you're thinking okay
joey's just going to give me a guide now
about why negative emotions are bad and
i shouldn't be so affected about
negative situations and i should just
stay positive and stay productive
yeah kinda
but it's deeper than that i'm about to
introduce you to a concept that has
served me extremely well throughout my
life and it's a concept that i adopted
from stoicism and if you adopt this
mindset fully you will not only be more
resilient to the chaos of life but the
chaos will actually make you stronger to
the point where you might actually
prefer a little bit of chaos so that you
can get stronger alright here's the
secret it's so simple it's almost
insulting the mindset is radical
acceptance now let's backtrack a bit
let's go back to why you might have been
frustrated about that guy saying [ __ ]
you or being stuck in traffic i think
it's because there is a fundamental
thing going on here you have a
fundamental rejection of reality as it
is you lived your life with a sort of
expectation of how reality actually is
or should be and you've been living in
this reality and something came along
and [ __ ] all over it and that thing that
[ __ ] all over it is actual reality and
that's sort of the key life is shitty it
produces [ __ ] but the key is to be fully
aware of the spectrum of [ __ ] that life
can produce all the way from just a
little bit poopy to like the ultimate
mega dump which is probably something
like you and everyone you know and love
dying and then the world ending or
something like that but actually the
mega mega dump would be everyone you
know and love dies and the world dies
but you're still somehow alive to watch
it all happen and then you die
meditating on and fully embracing and
accepting life as it is you know your
own mortality the fact that you're going
to die one day the fact that everyone
you know and love is going to die one
day this sounds super depressing for me
to say and it sounds super depressing to
think about and you might think you know
this is a bit of a mood killer i don't
really want to watch this video but this
is what the ancient stoic philosophers
did like seneca marcus aurelius and
epitidis and it actually helped keep
them grounded focused on the bigger
picture so that they could live a more
fulfilling life in the present moment
you know the point of all this isn't to
just spend all of your days thinking
about what your tombstone will look like
in 50 years 30 years tomorrow but to
focus on the things that are truly
important the things that are eternal
not the frivolous things that will fade
away the fact that you dented your car
the fact that you said something
embarrassing to your crush but to think
about your soul to think about the
virtues you are fostering the legacy
that you are leaving and the effect that
you have on the people around you and
the world that you're a part of certain
things in life seem tragic but also
inevitable we cannot avoid tragedy we
cannot avoid hardship it is woven into
the fabric of our reality and anytime we
are completely floored by it it's often
because we haven't considered it we we
didn't consider that it was even a
possibility so when it happens we don't
know what to do with that information
but if we live our life in acceptance of
life as it is the things that we can't
control and the things that we can then
it'll stop feeling like we're constantly
drowning in the waves of life splashing
on the shore
we'll become a surfer if we can reflect
on and fully accept the highs and lows
of life and just how high and just how
low those can get then we'll stop being
so surprised when bad things happen and
it's not like you're like oh yeah just
my luck you know bad things always
happened to me told you so and it's more
like okay yeah a bad thing happened to
me something bad happened to me outside
of my control
what is in my control what can i gain
from this and what can i do about it you
know that's what an attitude of
acceptance gives you and this attitude
isn't just hypothetically useful it's
also very practically useful when i
started adopting this mindset in my life
as i started to get into more stoicism i
would get less rattled when my editing
program would randomly crash in the
middle of an edit you know rather than
adobe premiere crashing for the 800th
time in two days and me going oh what
the [ __ ] are you kidding me i just lost
everything
you go
yeah
right hmm
okay
this happened i'm switching to final cut
pro you know if a fight breaks out at
the bar you're not gonna be like oh
what's going on who and you like join
the outrage you notice what's going on
you land a key punch to the throat if
you need to and you walk out of the bar
pro gamer move that's like ryan gosling
and blade runner stone cold anyways yeah
that's pretty much all i got for this
video i'm not gonna tie a nice bow on
this one i don't really feel like being
super poetic i'll do that next video
i'll save the production value for next
video so i hope this was helpful for you
and let me tell you about a hobby i
recently picked up involving stoicism
take it away future joey one of my
favorite things to do as of late is to
go on a very long moody nighttime drive
preferably in the rain and dive into
some of the most thought-provoking
ancient wisdom ever recorded right now
i'm diving into letters from a stoic by
seneca and obviously i'm not reading a
book while i'm driving i'm listening to
the audiobook and if unless you've been
living under a rock then you'll know
that the best and most convenient way to
listen to audiobooks is by using audible
which is today's video sponsor for those
of you who don't know audible is the
leading provider of spoken word
entertainment all in one place it has by
far the largest selection of audiobooks
on the entire internet if the book
exists there's a very high chance
there's an audiobook version that you
can find on audible and with an audible
membership every single month they send
you one credit which you can spend on
any audiobook of your choice regardless
of cost and you get to keep that book
forever if you cancel your membership at
any point you still keep your entire
library of audiobooks and if you've been
thinking about joining audible and
you've been kind of on the fence waiting
for a deal now's your chance because
they just launched their holiday offer
so for the first three months of your
membership you get 60
off your membership which means that for
the first three months it's only 5.95 a
month and if you factor in the fact that
they give you one free book credit
that's a really good deal you get like
heavily discounted audiobooks so it's
kind of a no-brainer so if you want to
take advantage of that offer all you
have to do is click my link in the
description below go to audible.com
better ideas or to make it really easy
for you just text better ideas to
500-500 so scoop up that holiday offer
join audible listen to some really
enriching audiobooks expand your mind
make yourself smarter and as usual have
a great time
what's up it's the third and final
version of joey here i forgot to film an
actually i didn't forget to film an
outro to the video my camera died
um if you liked this video the one that
i just edited and the one you just
watched um consider hitting the like
button because the like button actually
does help me do better as a youtuber it
lets youtube and the algorithm know that
this was a decent video and it might
have been helpful
and then it just pumps my bald head into
more people's homepages potentially
helping them out
so it helps me out helps everyone out
it's just a win-win if you're lurking
here and you haven't subscribed yet
consider subscribing because that also
you know helps the whole operation out
as well i'm really excited about next
video kind of hinted out hinted at a
higher production value um
so yeah that's the only hint i'll give i
don't know what else to say um other
than
stay tuned for next video thank you so
much for watching and we'll catch you in
the next video
you